i don't tell people that they're okay
the way they are now i say no no you
could be way more than you are
and they're relieved about that you see
because if you're in a dark and terrible
place
and someone says you're okay the way you
are then you don't know what to do about
that it's right no i'm not
i'm having a terrible time and i'm
hopeless you're okay the way you are
well then what what that's it that's it
that's where i am
and what do you want to tell a young
person you're 17. you're okay the way
you are it's like no you're not
you got 60 years to be better and you
could be way better you could be
incomparably better
across multiple dimensions and in
pursuing that better that's where you'll
find the meaning in your life
and that will give you the antidote to
the suffering i mean imagine you only
got 100 you only have a hundred thousand
dollars to go buy a house
and so you go by you go look at this
house and it's like jesus this house man
it's like it needs a lot of work
it's like well that's all you've got
well you're going to pretend that the
house is okay the way it is
are you going to look for where it's
rotten and where the plumbing doesn't
work and where the stove doesn't work
you have to go and look and see where
everything needs to be fixed
and that's like that is harsh man but
and then
in order to do that properly someone has
to have taught you look you aren't your
problems
you're most fundamentally that which if
it confronts its problems can solve them
and that's the hero myth in
in a nutshell by the way the hero is the
person who confronts
horrible chaotic potential and tames it
and makes something of it
right that's that's the fundamental
human story but the problem is is that
you have to face what you don't want to
face in order to fix it
and so you look at all the things about
yourself that need to be burned off that
need to be dispensed with
and that man especially at the beginning
especially if you're screwed up that
might be like 95
percent of you just has to go up in
flames and it's painful
even some of that stuff that you have to
burn off doesn't want to die
and it'll scream in agony while you're
burning it off it's not pleasant
but if you know that you're the thing
that can transcend your problems most
fundamentally
if you know you're the thing that if it
faces the problems can transcend them
then you have the faith that would
enable you to take stock of who you are
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday not to who someone else is
today because you need to be you
need to have a hierarchy of improvement
you need to be aiming some for something
and that means you're going to be lesser
than people who've always
already attained along that dimension
that can give rise to envy
so the question is who should you defeat
in the final analysis and the answer is
you should defeat your former self
you should be constantly trying to do
that and you're the right control for
yourself too because you're the one
who's had all your advantages and
disadvantages
and so if you want to compete fairly
with someone then you should be
competing with you
and it is the case and this is what we
were talking about too with regards to
the self-improvement of the fighter
as well if you're improving yourself
then what you are doing is competing
with your lesser self
and then you might also ask well what is
that lesser self and that lesser self
would be
resentful and bitter and aggressive and
vengeance seeking and all of those
things that go along with having a
negative moral character and those are
things that
interfere with your ability to progress
as you move forward through life
so it's very necessary to understand
that this is why
you know i've been stressing this idea
of personal responsibilities like well
personal responsibility is to compete
with yourself is to be slightly better
than yourself the next day
and it better in some way that you can
actually manage and that's humility it's
right like
well i'm a flawed person i've got all my
problems could i be
as good as person x it's like not the
right question the right question is
could you be
slightly better tomorrow than your
currently flawed self and the answer to
that
is if you have enough humility to set
the bar properly low
then you could be better tomorrow than
you are today
you might say well what's the right way
of being in the world if there is such a
thing
and it's not acting according to a set
of rules
it's attempting continually to transcend
the flawed thing that you currently are
and what's so interesting about that is
that the meaning and the meaning in life
is to be found in that pursuit
so i've been laying that out in these
discussions too because it said well
the the fundamental issue is that life
is tragic and difficult
very tragic and difficult for everyone
and
it's also tainted by malevolence things
are tragic and difficult but there's
always some stupid thing that you could
do or someone else could do that could
make it even worse than it has to be
so that's life and you need an antidote
to that because
that can embitter you constant contact
with that just the tragedy but
the tragedy combined with betrayal and
malevolence that makes it even worse
especially if it's self-induced okay so
you need something to set against that
so you don't get bitter and resentful
what do you said against that doing
something worthwhile
by your own definition say you need some
reason to get the hell out of bed on a
terrible day because you've got
something good to do
well what's the best thing you can do
transcend your
current wretched and miserable self
there's meaning to be found in that
and that's that's a meaning that's
associated with responsibility
one of the things that i've been trying
to lay out clearly is that
life is hard it's tainted by malevolence
and betrayal that can make you bitter
you need a meaning to offset that
where's the meaning to be found
not in rights not in impulsive pleasure
but in responsibility
you take responsibility for yourself so
you take care of yourself
if you're good at it you can you have
some excess left over to take care of
your damn family
if you're good at both of those then you
have some excess left over to take care
of your community
those are heavy burdens you pick up the
burdens you find that's meaningful
the best way to pick up the burden is to
continually improve yourself
and that's where the meaning is to be
found and so that meaning is in the
continual self transcendence
that's letting your old self die and the
new self be reborn